we're [ __ ] fancy it's not that you  can't it's that you're not willing to  give up dumb [ __ ] for a better life  you're not willing to go backwards  you're not willing to make yourself  dramatically happier to move out of your  home and downsize and go into a  different neighborhood you're not  willing to go backwards that to me is  fascinating the fact that things were  their home car watch clothes going out  is holding people back from a  substantially happier life is  fascinating to me and something that we  need to debate because at the end of the  day that one out that is all we've got  and so if I can absolutely push you one  tangible item I see some people have  pads and pens and I'm fascinated by that  go ready go to a [ __ ] F uck ing  retirement home spend time collect data  realise regret is the worst and do  something about it  [Music]  you